six former  administration officials last week wrote  that open letter urging the  administration to change course to  change strategy  is it time  it is time for us to  do what we have been doing and that time  is every day  every day it is time for us to agree  that  there are things and tools that are  available to us to slow this thing down  my god  i so direct transcript here okay it's  time for us to do what we have been  doing and that time is every day well i  okay in a way that makes sense so  whatever we're doing right now  it's it's time for us to be doing that  and so like whatever you're trying to  understand this whatever you're doing in  the present moment well it's obviously  time that you're doing that and so that  time is every day because you're always  living in the present moment so whatever  you're doing in that moment that's what  you're doing in that moment and that  time is every day all the time